hello guys and girls and welcome to
another python 3 tutorial this tutorial
is going to be covering the for loop the
for loop is used for
pretty much the same tasks as the while
loop they're completely interchangeable
typically you're going to see the while
loop uh being used for
um
it sounds kind of funny but i suppose i
would say finite or infinite uh tasks
and the for loop is usually used to be a
little bit more variable for like
uncertain kind of time frames and stuff
like that but that said uh the for loop
can actually be used for the same tasks
as the while loop
um and the while loop can do all of the
things a for loop can do i mean they're
completely interchangeable performance
wise action wise and all of that so
uh for this reason i
i would just say that it just comes down
to personal preference um i prefer the
for loop myself a lot of times the for
loop is much more condensed
or condensable than the while loop uh
but again it really just comes down to
personal preference and it just doesn't
matter so
anyway uh what i'd like to do now is
show you guys some examples of the for
loop and where you're gonna most often
see it because some people really like
myself included i do actually use both
um it just depends you know what the
situation is so
anyways uh let's go ahead and get
started so first what we're gonna want
is generally you're gonna see the for
loop being used to iterate through a
list and what iterate means is just go
through a list so let's make an example
list so we're going to name this example
list
and we're going to uh encase this list
and i'm just going to type in random
values you can do the same you can try
and copy my values if you want but it's
not necessary
i'm just putting some variables or some
values in here
so in a previous tutorial
with the variables i was showing you
guys
that if you add like multiple variables
here
uh it's going to unpack right and so
it's going to try to unpack all of these
values right
but if you just have one and again if
you didn't have enough on either side if
they weren't equal it would it would
throw an error but if you're just
assigning a single
variable here this is totally fine to do
it's going to assign this entire list to
this variable but if you did like
example list var that would throw an
error you would need as many variables
as here because it's going to try and
unpack the list
just as a quick aside so now what we're
going to do is we're going to say 4x in
example list what do we want to do so
the way to think about this is basically
for each eye so maybe what i'll do is
actually to make it a little more uh
understandable for each uh number
in example list what do we want to do so
what it's doing is it's creating a
variable here right each number now
becomes a variable that each step of the
way these numbers are being assigned to
this variable each number and obviously
example list is corresponding to example
list so we'll hit enter
and if you didn't notice already by now
with like the while loop and all that
when you make one of these loops and you
hit enter it automatically tabs it over
for you so if you're coming from like
maybe another language
or not at all from any programming
language you have to usually do this
or actually you don't have to really do
it in python you have to do it you must
have this space here in other languages
typically you've got like curly braces
and you come down and you just you could
put all you wanted over here and then
most people say you should have good
standards and you should automatically
indent it yourself
but it is not necessary in other
languages in python it is but luckily
usually it's going to automatically
indent for you so it is just fine so it
makes your code pretty automatically
so that's kind of nice
anyway so you must have that indentation
and and this indentation will apply
throughout the entire loop so in order
to get out of that loop i'll show you in
a moment um what you would need to do
but for now let's just say print
uh each
number
so we'll save and run that and as you
can see it just iterated through the
entire list in order one five six one
six seven eight nine three hundred forty
five fifty three five pretty cool uh but
now what you can do too is then you come
down here
and
we'll just say print continue program
like that run it and you'll see here
that it continues the program after the
for loop because it's not under the same
indentation
but if you hit tab and you indent this
along with this for loop you're going to
see continue program for every number so
when we run this
you can see that at each step of the way
it continued the program so just keep
that in mind that you're that's how your
indentation really matters uh another
quick thing i'll show you guys real uh
real fast is
um
first what can happen sometimes if is
this right you've copy and pasted a lot
of code maybe and it's not indented so
what you can do though is you can
highlight all the code like the what's
called a block of code and you can
highlight it and then hit tab and it
will tab the code over by that same
token if your
code is too far tabbed over that also
will not work it literally won't run
well
python3 just keeps throwing me for a
loop apparently that's okay it's going
to go ahead and run hold on let me try
something else i'll come down here
paste and then let's do this all right
python three
that was okay as well
well at least in python two seven you
can't do that
but anyway i'll tell you anyways how you
can fix this uh just so it does look
right because
even though apparently python 3 is more
accepting of improper standards than
python 2 7 you should still try your
best to give good standards so because
it gets very messy uh when you want to
do maybe another for loop down here and
do some stuff right uh so anyways what
you can do to move a block the other way
is highlight it hold ctrl and it's uh
the open bracket so you can hit that a
couple times and it tabs it over if you
don't know what i'm talking about it's
this symbol right here like this key you
hit that while holding ctrl and that'll
shift it over
so that's that
but now uh back to
some more stuff about the for loop i was
telling you guys that you can use the
for loop much like you use while loop as
a counter and it's much better as a
counter
and here's why so if you remember the
for loop that we wrote
uh or the while loop rather i believe
that came out to be four total lines of
code but instead with the for loop you
can do 4x in
range and range is a built-in function
in python
so first i'll just show you guys what
it's going to do 1 comma 11 and all we
want to do is just print x for now so
let's run that real quick and you'll see
that what it did is obviously our
previous program but then it did one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
not eleven and the way a range works is
it starts at the first number and goes
all the way up to the ending number or
whatever it is
now um
a couple of uh or one thing to note
range is a built-in python function so
you don't have to import it and it will
literally make that range of numbers for
you in python 2 7
python's three point or python 3.3s
um
version of range here has actually been
back ported to python 2.7
and it is x range it's known as x range
in python 2 7 so x range like that and
what is beneficial about this range
function over the python 2.7
range function
is when you do something like
um in python 3 3 and you say range
1 and like this number
what it's going to do in python 27 is
literally generated a list that is this
from one to this number whatever it is
um
and obviously that's going to use a lot
of your virtual memory so your ram and
it's probably going to max out your ram
before it completes the operation
but
in python 33 or if you use what's called
x range in python 2 7 it turns this into
what's known as a generator and
eventually we'll talk more about
generators later on but what a generator
does is it only visits that operation
once it doesn't store it in the memory
but it it will count through so
pretty interesting stuff there
but more on that kind of stuff later
since this is meant to just be basics
so that pretty much covers uh the for
loop a couple of examples of the for
loop here both as a counter and then
also as an iterator through a list
but really this iterated through a list
only actually used a generator function
to do so
um so anyways
that is that
so hopefully you guys learned something
new hopefully you guys are enjoying my
tutorials if you have any questions feel
free to post them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until the next video